okay hello everyone welcome to another W
from language design review um part of
our incremental language development
series um and our first item is tree
outline okay so um
yeah if you open up uh uh focus of 0.5
first um right so we've looked at this
design before um and you know that that
was kind of representative of the
previous design and your comment was
essentially you know it's quite precious
was the word you use there essentially
you know too much ink on the page really
um and so the focus of this iteration
has been to try and sort of simplify um
so if you open up simplest State um we
can probably Skipper of the other
two um yeah okay so uh here yeah as I
say tree mock is just meant to represent
tree with an appearance option set to
opener um so so here is the new sort of
design as you can see it's kind of um a
lot cleaner um we've got rid of uh sort
of you know all of the branch lines and
now we just have these sort of vertical
scope lines um uh yeah leaves are
bulleted with those those pale uh
squares as you can see openers obviously
sorry um inner nodes
have it is
yes slow isn't it right so so this is a
war from language mockup um of something
that would require you know some degree
of C++ support I would
imagine
um but yes um so uh yeah so that's
that's that's the fully expanded tree of
the the thing above obviously it would
open in the fully closed State um so so
what are these numbers down here uh the
numbers correspond to uh you know the
path to the the the node that's
currently being hovered over so what is
this so first of all I like this but how
about some green just because to liven
it up a
bit sure I should say that this hasn't
graphic design haven't seen this yet so
so yeah um certainly open to to all of
those sorts of
suggestions um okay but I think okay so
then an ordinary tree I mean if I take
the same tree
and I just display it in our usual tree
form right mhm
um
okay so now does this have any kind of
rollover uh so Oh you mean um I don't
believe
so I imagine someone from the trees team
could probably comment sort of better
than me on that I don't think it
does I mean is it obvious that we want
this or is it because you know it's it's
kind of thing where where you're showing
the you know the the webbing inside so
to speak by showing those numbers and it
may be that the the tree you know is
presenting something and the fact that
that's the one three branch is just
totally confusing and
irrelevant
sure I I think um uh and Ian correct me
if I'm wrong but but I think that
another option was potentially we could
show the names of the nodes there
instead is that right but why aren't we
why are we showing something different
here than we're showing here yeah well
so the numbers that are being shown on
the outline mockup is for consistency
with data
set data set also shows the position
that you're Hing over I know but why in
if you scroll down I have a section on
this and I have an example data set so
we can see it uh oh there we go it's the
next one hover
effect I know this is consistent with
data set but I'm just I don't understand
why this is has anything to do with data
set I mean this is a tree there's no way
of of showing a data set as a tree is
there yeah maybe there should be I mean
there isn't right now I think there is
give me a second I'll figure it
out I you know somebody else speak up
here because I mean many uses of this
tree I just think that this is confusing
to see these numbers
here yeah if you give a data set to
expression tree with the second argument
data set you get a tree version of that
data
set
okay
totally an inspiringly large number of
examples here but
whatever
okay
okay now how do I get it in the new
form I don't think it would
um yes um
although I don't think that's going to
work
but I'd like to see a more complicated
data set that's my
point IUS just killed it
totally
yeah absolutely
dead okay I don't believe in The
annotation thing
okay I think it's just going to confuse
people what why is it thought to be
useful Ian speak up is it
useful yes it for example when you drill
down into a sub tree you would know what
position you're
at at your naviga the tree okay which
you wouldn't
know so you claim you need that just as
you do in data set to know where you are
yes well I mean let's look at the
examples because that you also do have
the path written out at the top of the
tree as well as you do in data
set
yeah right I think the two together help
you you see where you're at and then you
see where you're going
right right click on the double Chevron
where you are and so we can see you've
got the the path at the top
now with the with the tree
okay but but if this was a you can have
associations you could have named
branches and trees
true yes
yes so then what does this look like
because in data set doesn't look like a
list with numbers in it right it's a
list of keys no I understand that but in
data set it does not displayed this
way it's displayed with little greater
than signs between the the elements here
am I making sense mhm
yes um this down here might be displayed
this way but this is
not
okay
I mean the consistent hover thing for
this is just a null list isn't
it
right well in which case I mean is it
sort of better to just not show anything
as I'm doing
now that's fine so long as the spacing
is okay
underneath uh yeah it's just using an
attached cell so it doesn't you know
it's not taking up any space that's
good um although I mention again this is
this is just a mockup that I've put
together this is not you know I don't
think at all representative of the
actual implementation of what this would
be um so yeah so you've just been
exploring this um but basically yes if
you if you click on those double uh
right Chevrons that appear when you're
hovering over you know um a leaf or an
inner nodes then it will drill down uh
to that node or that leaf um and then
you can sort of step back up B sign
position that's kind of detail we
probably don't go need to go into now um
that is kind of one interesting question
in there that maybe we could Circle back
to
um but uh yeah so then this is just to
give you an example with kind of you
know other
content
um what is this font
here uh I think I'm just picking it up
from uh the output style but obviously
we we could Define our own style for
this I mean I mean this is a Ian this is
how would this
look oh
here oh I need the duty oh you need the
WID
yeah uh no no no okay
mind
you know I have to say that this font is
a bit ugly
here tree uses tree uses uh standard
form for its format
type do we think that's right I think
so it's really ugly here in text I mean
what looks like text
that consistent with what like Edge
labels and vertex labels and graph use
just standard it's actually it's
different from graph um and it's because
these aren't usually labels they're
arbitrary wol from language
expressions you know we're not expecting
text to be the default thing in all
cases when you use tree You're Expecting
Expressions so I think standard form is
the right thing it'd be nice to make
sure that we can have some Global op you
know thing here that switches all of
them so you don't have to put text you
could say format uh I believe format
type format
um format type goes to traditional form
is that enough uh that's in treeck
though don't don't evaluate that just in
case we freeze up again they do it in
the tree sorry
yeah
that looks much
nicer
okay I mean the problem is people always
leave these things with
defaults um I think not for this meeting
but that's a discussion we should have
is about to change
that
okay um okay so here again there's some
consistency with data set this is you
know how do we alide uh uh you know long
lists of uh um items um and uh yeah this
is this is not an interactive Mark why
why is this and the fact that these
aren't labeled properly is just because
there's a mockup is that right because
these would normally just actually have
names like Cordelia and so on correct
right yeah it's just yeah for the sake
of putting something there um but yes
the fact there's you know data set there
you can see like you know 61 total 27
total Etc and so I've just kind of
copied that here nice um that yeah and
then if you have um uh you know if if if
the current route because of course you
can drill down um so you know the root
or the node that is serving as the root
uh has too many you know items to to
display at once um too many leaves too
many children's display at once and if
you scroll down um you can see that we
display a scroll bar uh for the you know
sort of for the for
the um the branch coming from what is
serving currently as the
rout again copying the start is
commenting on our live stream that our
graph label layout is still still bad
after all these years I don't know that
that you need to when labels are
arbitary shapes you need to relay out
the
nodes this is probably the wrong group
to talk about that in I'm not sure
what's wrong with this particular one no
this is known um there's a family of
Tidy layout algorithms for trees that
should be
implemented
well that seems
important is that on your plate
yes seems important to me this looks
good I have one comment just from the
whole beginning of this is you know the
only
aspect of this
design that feels a little bit still
precious are those
dots okay so so I went back and forwards
on this so
the okay so so all the children of of
one right you know they're all at the
same level in the tree and so they all
should have the same indentation and if
you don't put something there right so
in other words if you so so so you know
nodes with children are bulleted with
those about what about is Jeremy here by
the
way uh no no he's not he needs to be
because this is a Design Story right we
have is here I think I'm here okay
okay um right I think this would look
better if instead of a dot it was a
little tiny fragment of the
vertical see what I'm
saying so it would kind of like Bend out
from the main branch and then onto the
no no I'm just saying I'm just saying
that just as this is spanning see this
vertical you know line there's a span
from here there's a span from here I'm
suggesting that instead of a instead of
a different graphic Motif here of a of a
bullet that instead it's just a fragment
of that you understand what I'm
saying a ver just a just a bar but the
bars don't connect yeah they don't
connect now is that inconsistent or or
silly from a point of view of what the
tree means I was going to say would it
be confusing or weird that it's on the
same sort
of level as 13 below it and that the
lines might
somehow indicate that it's somehow
associated with
13 whereas they're the dots sort of show
that they're kind
of it it is at the same
level well I mean we agree that it's at
the same level the question is is it
associated
with it's not going to look that way I
don't think just no more than this line
here looks associated with this line
here
MH
I think that would make this design look
cleaner Also let's go green as they
say for these lines okay if you can make
a mark up Billy that would be great
okay hello can you hear me we can now
sorry my connection dropped um but I'm
back
um right so so yes XML is obviously a
case we want to deal with slightly
differently um I think that one is a
live mockup the first one yes um and so
you know we're not displaying the XML
object of document uh nor the
Declaration we're just starting with the
root of the actual content um and then
all of that other stuff gets put into a
tool tip but I've got a section on that
below um but here I I have a few
alternate layouts for just the you know
an XML tree itself um so we could also
have the closing tags um and then if you
scroll down one more uh we can show a
preview of what's actually in a closed
tag right because I mean it's not
particularly useful in that case to just
see sort of you know sale sale sale um
so I'm showing the you know like the
first a preview of the first element in
sale I like it I also think we should
have the closing tags
here
okay I think it doesn't waste much space
and it makes the whole thing less
confusing
now how does it know to go Blue for this
here it's just looking at XML element
and saying that's a special
case uh right and this is specifically
for appearance goes to quote
XML um how how will we get that what
will def
that so um I think I have a note about
that just above you know it would be set
by the appropriate thing so for for
example I would imagine that again
someone will probably comment on this
best than I can but you know that there
are functions that it would that would
sort of obviously set that uh appearance
option so import I mean this thing here
import comma tree would probably go to
this
yeah
okay and what can I copy paste from
here well I mean that's that's more
general question which is that contents
of these openers actually be sortable
editable have some degree of interaction
and I I sort of of wonder whether I mean
I guess John would would sort of you
know maybe has an idea of how this might
or or whether that's kind of you know
possible John do you want to comment on
that please sorry I missed the prologue
to
that whether these things
basically
yeah whe whether sorry you were talking
over one another and I couldn't this
kind of tree structure could it be made
editable
or at least
selectable
um I don't
know okay how would I get back from this
tree
display
to uh the raw XML
elements would normal do that or what
would what would do
that
expression I see
yeah uh that's a tree mock remember so
it's not going to behave properly in
that
sense I was going to say font wise given
that this is a special rendering we
should make these angle brackets a
little less
angly I'm saying sure yeah yeah makes
sense
especially given that we've got so many
other angly you know equilateral
triangles and things like that going on
here make
sense yeah yeah
okay yeah I think I I think adding
editability would be a significant
challenge okay well let's not worry
about that right
now okay I recommend here maybe this
goes to a smaller font or something this
content sure
yeah I can mock that
up um so here's the actual annotation so
I you know I was saying previously that
we don't include certain parts of the
tree in the tree outline um so any
metadata which relate to you know the
entire XML document uh and not like a
specific you know node um they'll be
displayed in a tool tip next to the root
and so that's an example X document um
if you scroll down that's what its tool
tip would look like and then if you
scroll down even further if you then
hover over the I next to
note uh in in the in the actual tree
sorry in the uh in the cell yeah there
we go that you can see that sort of
that's what it would look
like and you would display the eye in
the actual
thing
yes Ethan on our live stream is asking
about interactive Json viewer and doing
the same thing with
Json I don't see any reason why that
shouldn't be couldn't be made to
work yeah I assume we'll need like
eventually in need like an appearance
goes to Json appearance goes to file
system but what does Json typically
import
as um well we have two forms there's
Json and there's raw Json
raw J but they the import form is is
lists of rules isn't it ye yes but if
you do raw Json then it's uh nested
lists and associations so associations
for objects and lists for arrays I see I
think it's slightly cleaner than list
but unlike XML where we have an explicit
XML element we don't have a Json element
and we don't think we need one or do
we I think we do not need one Json is
basically lists and
associations but so you're saying
that we could take that and we can do
this tree appearance how do we treey and
do this tree appearance on
that you understand what I'm
saying for example I think if you did
like import a
Json uh file comma tree that
would set the appearance option to Json
as well as construct a
tree similarly expression tree could set
the appearance
option
okay um yeah so this is basically the
same as above but there's method data
that's relating to a specific node and
so you can see that now there are two of
those I icons you know one uh for the oh
that should have
worked you actually in the notebook is
The Notebook selected there we
go
yeah so the thing I don't like I mean
with this if we're really just doing
cruddy formatting here with standard
form why are we doing text
here why are we processing this but
we're not processing other
things do you understand my question uh
yeah I'm thinking um so firstly I mean
the style of tool tips is by default I
know this sort of
thing um so just you know just as an as
a consistency with other tool tips um
secondly there's more of an argument
here for making things compact I
guess I don't understand why internal
subset how does that come from the the
text that's up there just says doc
type uh confused I'm confused what is
that internal subset thing going is that
just an implementation thing right now
I'm sorry I may have got that wrong Ian
can you comment if
that's I may have just got that wrong
from from from the XML Tre
above perhaps I know there's a few there
it's the XML object as opposed to XML
element and the XML object ref page
documents these
different I don't think it makes sense
you're showing something with this whole
laboratory structure don't have internal
subset Arrow whatever because it's not
it's not even close to that that's not
what it is I mean you know if this was a
if this thing imported as a rule for
example that's not what what you should
be displaying
here does that make sense hey we got to
we got to live up here right I guess the
idea being that if this is meta
information and we're we want it to be
displayed it should be displayed without
a bunch of XML tags on it right well it
should be displayed and whatever look
it's about consistent with what we're
doing for the main content right yeah is
is the metadata always going to be
fairly textual for XML or do we have to
worry about the the problem that hean
said earlier where there's arbitrary
Expressions that are potentially going
to
be showing up I think it'll always be
text for
XML okay anyway so that needs to get
fixed right all right what else do we
have to look at here you want to look at
something about this Baseline
thing uh just there's a Slightly bizarre
case where right so it's it's the top
thing right should the Baseline of the
always be the Baseline of what the
current route is and it just means that
if you don't do that you get that kind
of or if you do do that rather you get
sort of the the the the path when you've
drilled down sort of displaying
above right that to
example the top example it says a a
right and then it's got the tree and
then it's got y y I just wanted to check
that you don't think that looks slightly
odd that the Baseline when you drill
down is you know has stay with what the
current route is and therefore you kind
of get this odd path the PA is thing
with a decorator above I don't think
that's a problem I think it's quite nice
actually I mean in a case like
this you know it's a little weird that
you have a borderless tree you know
construct here that this thing is just
hanging but it's probably in actual use
cases it's probably going to be fairly
easy to understand and if you don't like
it put a frame on
it I mean it probably be good for the
tree thing to have a frame Arrow true
option
sure okay um yeah and then I guess the
only other question I had was um right
so you know I'm proposing here that we
have
tree
uh okay so I'm sorry sorry Billy just
mocked up but he didn't change it to
Green which is a shame and he also
changed the form of these
openers was that intentional Billy uh
yeah but there is it is green just
because it's not coming through um and
yes I did change those but uh oh yeah it
is slightly green yeah think it could be
greener personally I think the filled in
triangles are just it's just a little
easier to
see you know the things you can click on
and and and what's been opened and
what's been closed yeah I kind of agree
I kind of agree maybe there's an
intermediate case here but I Billy why
did you you change that to the outline I
was thinking more of like you know when
trying to interact to see that the
change happens as well so if you like
hover over it maybe it fills in but it
could also kind of hover the other way
where it's filled in and then you get
the lighter hover so it would look like
do we have a hover effect right now in
this yes it goes
blue go bright green I mean it could
clearly go bright
green sure sure
I mean given that we're going green as
trees you
know well what do people think about
these vertical I think they look better
than these I think they're more
integrated yeah they definitely have a
little more weight to
them well I mean they just make more
sense this this is just a different
design element that we're not seeing
anywhere else
here okay let's assume this is going to
work this looks good let's implement it
go ahead
well yes what do you want say I don't
know because it's okay so where one is
open there
right and you've also got one three op
that has a solid line so you can clearly
see what its children are with these you
know with these vertical lines above and
below it does make it ever so slightly
less easy to kind of just PA what's a
child of
because that line
continues like for is no 14's not part
of that three um never mind right yeah
but but but it almost looks like it
is well okay but it maybe needs some
other device which we're not going to
solve here I think it looks better than
having bullets sure I understand that
that has to be solved maybe these things
aren't quite as tall as
this okay but they're integrated with
the the form of these
things sure sure makes
sense okay should we move on okay thank
you
yeah these are very nice this very nice
stuff
thanks
um all right next
item highlight
text yeah so this is a originally a
function repository function that Rick
put together um I figured it makes some
sense since we have John Ling in the
background he can either opine or groan
at the idea of
inserting style markups in text based on
patterns
um that's the general purpose of this
particular function but what is the
result what is what is the thing that it
prod the current result is a frame box
that has a bunch of style rules but but
what is it what is the thing that you
get I mean so is is this something where
highlighted text or whatever it's
whatever it's supposed to be called I
don't understand because there are many
text annotators MH including text
element and so on how does this relate
to those right I mean I think this is
most closely related to what text
element is doing in terms of you're
getting back a decorated object that is
not obviously just a string it is not a
a row with a bunch of styles in it okay
I we got to be consistent right we've
got we've got a certain number of
these these kinds of things
and I'm back I
gu
um well do you want to just do you
know input form on one of those outputs
and so we know what the hell we're
talking about yeah not seen this well
maybe I have seen this function before
but it's been a quite a while I me
because this is made at for being a
resource function I couldn't really
Define another separate object that had
like formatted definition so if I
remember correctly it's just a string
with inline standard form
stuff but if I were doing this
separately as like a sandalon thing
there would be like you know a
highlighted text type of wrapper or
something that does something different
rather than just baking stuff into the
string um
look I want to know how is this
consistent with text elements and the
other kinds of annotations for Strings
okay because we've got a whole bunch of
annotations for Strings we're trying to
do do we I mean I don't I don't think we
want to implement this necessarily as
the function exists here but I think
there is some
interesting elements of it particularly
you know the idea of taking strings and
string annotations and doing stylistic
markup based on on patterns you know
there's there's an option included the
last example there that Rick put of this
trimming threshold that's really useful
when working with large sections of text
you know I
don't also it's not clear to me that
there's any relationship here to text
element I mean text element is a
semantic markup this is a
purely you know how does positional
markup how does this relate to
snippet
yeah I mean the the trimming threshold
is is effectively using what snippet
does but we're highlighting it around
you know in this case it's trying to
highlight this particular
harah instance within a large body of
text and what it does is it compresses
around that detected
element snippet gives n number of lines
this is either you know you could
potentially have lines or characters but
say you know I want this autoc
compressed around some element that I'm
looking for so we Allied content before
and after it to you know 200 characters
you could cut it down to 15 or something
and you'd see the highlighted sections
but you'd have less
context
right right I don't I don't think we
want to add yet another markup on text
that is just for highlighting but I
think you know looking at as eai said
text element is primarily concerned with
semantics
and I don't know that we have a general
markup for text that is done around
style and where that
integrates you know maybe it's just not
particularly useful to to go through and
say okay I want to find
instances of this particular phrase in a
body of text and just highlight it or
change the styling um right we are
running out of time here so let's just
see what what things I mean look
this this idea that we're highlighting
by pattern is something we don't have
for Expressions
either
right right what you do is go in and you
for Expressions you go in and you say
map at some part or some such other
thing right so here that's kind of
inconvenient and I don't know whether
this is useful I I really just don't
know I mean like I can imagine wanting
to highlight section headers or
something that are defined by some kind
of
pattern like you know
star a star at the beginning of a line
or something you know what I really
would like us to look holistically at
all the things like text all the things
that are you know annotations of
strings okay does that make sense I
would like to look at more L yes I would
like to look at that but this is not
that okay this is a very small oneoff
function um but looking through I like
it we have a number of bit functions
it's I like it I think it's a useful
function um the only question is which
which direction does the three mean
three from the left
right uh yes or yeah we're counting
we're counting from our zero bit no no
no no that's three from the right then
three from the right so which is it I
don't think it's correct to do three
from
the oh God I mean it's I don't think
from the left is necessarily well
defined when we're talking about
integers yeah I mean if you look at the
examp example down below this you know
we you can use this principle if we're
counting from the right to flip bits
that aren't set in the
integer I see I set that makes sense the
10th bit of well also we could have a
minus thing that that starts from the
first nonzero
bit am I making
sense right I want to count I want to
count to the right from the first
nonzero
bit
I think this is
okay let's do
it well except bit set and so on those
count from the right is that correct
yeah I mean this is this is literally
using bit set I see that exor of bit set
effectively yeah fine let's do
it this is a utility function I think
Rick originally wrote a a function
repository version of it but it
effectively lets you inject a hold into
a function that isn't normally held um
the way that it does it is by using a a
pure function that's hold all complete
and injecting it unevaluated but I'm
sorry what is this trying to do so
unevaluated prior to function
evaluation so that print held ver
function there that this hold argument
of print is basically a version of print
that holds its arguments prior to
printing okay but so so this thing here
yeah would be I mean forget this is a
super confusing way to do it I mean the
this here doesn't work okay because this
didn't get you got to run the
definition
right yeah this is an interesting
wrapper I mean this is a this is a good
idea this is a good idea yeah I think it
solves the problem of there various
specialized cases where you want to have
a held version of another function and
we don't want to introduce a bunch of
hold
variance to functions um I think there I
like this idea we should have had this
idea
before so this
passes so if if you want to look at the
definition you can no no no no no no I I
just want to know this passes
unevaluated there so if I were to say
identity
here
okay so it'll pass to the identity
function 1+ one without so it's the
equivalent of identity of unevaluated 1+
1 is that correct correct yes
y this is a nice thing this is
useful
uh it be hold arguments or held I think
it should be held
arguments I would think so
too okay yeah H let me think about
withheld arguments no no no cuz this is
like is this an applied function that's
what I'm thinking right I mean it's kind
of like a reverse
applied would
be you know this ISS hold applied isn't
it right yep that's sense or
or is it hold applied is is it the is
the direct analog of reverse
applied that is it it there's some sort
of commutative diagram is thing here I
mean it's kind of like this
is It's inserting a reverse here just as
this is essentially unevaluated applied
is that
correct right un right unevaluated
applied would be directly analog right
it's not actually inserting a hold
anywhere the only problem with that is
it sounds bad I don't know why I just
yeah I understand I
understand but it is conceptually unal
yeah that is technically probably the
more correct name but it just yeah I
just don't like
it well maybe held applied as the middle
ground yeah I'm thinking held applied
held applied is a little weird because
it's two past
participles MH yes and and we didn't we
didn't use reversed apply
how about just
held
um
uh
sorry sorry what were you suggesting
just
held I don't think that's
right I don't think that's right held of
F I don't think that's right because
it's not the F that's held
right
um
holding we don't we don't have anything
else that sort of temporarily sets
attributes to the thing
that it's being applied to
right I mean this doesn't work
attributes but it's effectively
similar
well gosh we need a name here I'm not
sure what it should be but we are out of
time here so to be continued okay Circle
back to the name
but okay all right see you guys soon
thanks a lot thanks all bye for
now